long I'm going to read some advice from
the 19 I think it's 20s or 30s
um and we're going to see if you guys
think this is good advice
how to land him so how to get how to get
you a man
show and show him you can have fun on a
cheap date but don't overdo it
yeah yes 100 yeah okay don't let your
parents treat him like a treat to him
like a potential husband
um what what I'm just reading I'm this
is ask your parents to disappear when
you're entertaining double date with a
gay happily married couple let him see
what it's like
I would say hell no tell his friends
nice things about him
yeah yeah hype your man up um send his
mother a birthday card yes ask his
mother for her recipes yes definitely
talk to his father about business and
agree that taxes are too long okay you
know what that sounds like a great Pro
tip actually
the taxes are too yeah that's funny
that's funny by his sister's children an
occasional present yes yeah do that on a
first date tell him you aren't thinking
of getting married
oh okay so he doesn't feel the pressure
that's a weird advice for the 1920s or
30s
I'm just saying good advice or bad
advice bad it shouldn't be between good
first day talking about will you marry
me like maybe the third one don't talk
about how many children you want
to see what's wrong no that's actually
quite important one yeah okay if he's a
fisherman learn to skill and clean fish
yes yes oh that's interesting don't
don't tell him everything about yourself
at the start hold something in reserve
yes yeah when you're out strolling with
him don't insist on stopping at every
shop window yes please I disagree please
don't tell him how much your clothes
cost
yes learn to sew learn to sew oh I'm
interested because 22-22. learn to sew
and wear something you've made yourself
yes
a lot yes learn to solve I want to see
Pastor sewn into my trousers don't
gossip about him
oh this is interesting never let him
know he's the only one even if you have
to stay home one or two nights a week
what the hell well this is what you're
recording right yeah yeah what do you
guys think no no
definitely need to know if I don't know
I am not doing anything serious that is
terrible that's the worst thing I've
ever had in my life well I think back
then maybe they weren't sleeping with
more than one person
back then they weren't sleeping yeah you
could go on multiple dates with men
without sleeping with them and I think
like women should do that but they don't
but they don't they'll bang on the first
day so it's like if a woman makes a guy
think that he's not the only one he'll
run away she will decide that she will
never be she's joining the broadcast
Recreation don't
um don't be a pushover when he's trying
to make a date
that's terrible
that's terrible advice all right very
early in your dating why not get a
favorite song that you both regard as
your own as I start to like it's like
your song that's cute yeah it's like a
shoe collection find out about the oh
this is actually good advice find out
about the girls he hasn't married don't
repeat the mistakes they made
that would be useful don't discuss your
former boyfriends yeah
yes don't have any if you are widowed or
divorced don't constantly discuss your
former husband same thing be flexible if
you just got if he decides to skip the
dance and go rowing on the lake go even
if you were wearing your best evening
gown yeah I agree with that have fun yep
hi hide your Phi Beta Kappa key if you
own one later on Junior later on Junior
can play with it what's up so it's a
sorority key what does that mean what is
that that's a U.S one I don't know turn
wolves into husband material by assuming
they have honor
turn wolves oh so you're saying like
turn the bad boy into a husband by like
basically assuming he has honor so like
treating him I assume the best in him
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think it's
possible yeah why do you hesitating I
don't know it's just like the it's not
easy for a guy to be swayed like that I
think it takes a bit more than just
honoring the guy
because when you when you do that to a
guy who's not in a position to want to
when you do that to a bad guy a wolf in
that case you're just get you're just
leaving yourself open to be taken
advantage of in my opinion you know how
they say you can't turn a hoe into a
housewife why are you trying to turn a
bad boy into a house exactly he will do
it on his own time and that's where he's
ready women think they can fix men in
that regard yeah you can't listen listen
by the way the the the the advice was
saying the woman should assume he has
honor and will switch up his ways to for
the right word oh yes oh yeah it's a
it's a mental thing they're saying like
don't assume he's like don't assume he's
a wolf or else that's what you're gonna
see and I think this is possible yeah
that that's definitely possible yeah I
know guys who would change up entirely
if they met the right girl tomorrow so
that's that's definitely the case learn
where to draw the line but do it
gracefully um yes remain Innocent but
not ignorant yeah oh my God these are
amazing make your home comfortable when
he calls large ashtrays comfortable
chairs
learn learn to play poker machine
man if if he's Rich tell him you like
his money the honesty will Intrigue him
Matt nah
I think that that's like I don't think
there's nothing I don't feel there's
nothing wrong with that like woman uh
women are hard wired women are
hard-wired I expect men to provide so
she's attracted to a man that's rich
yeah I like your money I don't think a
man's trying to hear it but you'll leave
if he loses the money no no I don't
think it's like that like men don't want
to feel like they're going to work for
nothing no no because you could be like
babe thank you so much for going to work
I really appreciate what you're
contributing to the household it means
the world to me you know like let him
know that you like that he's gainfully
employed
if it said you didn't meant if it said
tell him you like his money but say it
gracefully
you're telling him but listen I love how
much money
I love the house okay whatever what
about you what about you're such a
hard-working man oh yeah the thing is by
saying it by saying it like that you're
respecting his work ethic Yeah by saying
it like that I like your bread and it's
nice that's not what he's trying to
that's not what that's not what he's
trying to hear no no never let him
believe oh this is never let him believe
your career is more important to you
than marriage yes yes
buy or buy him an amusing or
particularly appropriate present every
once in a while but don't make it too
expensive yes
I like cheap funny gifts clip and mail
him a funny cartoon that means something
to both of you and don't tell dirty
stories
full gift I think yeah I think that's
the point is do do something even if
it's free to let them know you thought
of him
um stop being a mama's girl don't let
him think he'll have trouble with his
mother don't think let him think he'll
have in-law trouble even if you know he
will
oh this one is so funny because last one
is so funny okay
point
out to him that the death rate of single
men is twice that of married man
what do we think all these good so far
more hits a few misses okay I have one
more article I was gonna read them today
is women I'll tell you I feel like the
first I feel like the first half sounded
like it come from a place a lot of
things come from a place of respect I
found out I mean it got a bit left after
but I feel definitely feel like the
first batch was definitely a place of
respect lose you in and then when you're
talking about like get like a little bit
of um like a gift for
what was it like the for his his nieces
yeah like I feel like you're showing
that you want to be integrated into his
family it's showing intention yeah and
and that's that's all that people are
trying to see now
okay so I have one more so this is
nine as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible